well hello hi keisha
where are you today by the way i'm in la
can i just say
i listened to your entire album top to
bottom
change your mind one too many we were
smashes oh my gosh thank you thank you
so good you never i mean you really
never disappoint
oh yeah i can disappoint stick around
but i i hope i don't with this album i
had such a great time making it
and uh yeah i'm really happy with it so
uh anxious
people get to hear it all now oh yeah me
too
so before we even get to the music
congratulations on your recent cma
nominations
male vocalist of the year entertainer of
the year
how does that feel and how did you hear
the news
oh my gosh euphoric uh
it gets sweeter i'll i'll tell you that
much it gets
oh so sweet um i heard about it by
waking up to about 26
texts from everybody
it's a it's a strange feeling when you
turn your phone on you have a flurry of
text you're like
this is either really bad news or really
good news it's not somewhere in the
middle
that's glad it was really good deans
yeah yeah well you've won a lot of
awards so like where do you keep all
these things
my mom has a few of them and um oh well
i wouldn't be here without my mom
driving around all the gigs and
you know all that back in the day yeah
she's fantastic
so she takes good care of them that's
nice um
you're never afraid to do something
different whether it's a song
a sound a collaboration this album is no
exception
would you define yourself as a risk
taker
no more a curiosity seeker
and and just following my instincts of
curiosity
uh without holding myself back you know
i don't even think
i've never thought in in even in terms
of uh pushing boundaries
i think it more about not stopping
myself
from going there which is a different
approach to everything
yeah yeah the speed of now i feel like
so much has changed in 2020 the speed of
everyone's lives
making everybody reflect has your
priorities changed over this past year
well yeah uh
but i but i feel like a lot of them were
they were heading in the right direction
anyway
um you know uh
i've had to learn everything the hard
way yeah
and all the experiences i've been
through leading up to 2020
really put me in a much better place so
i
yeah but at the same time i mean it's
it's yeah we're
i'm re-evaluating my life constantly of
course you know
just moving evolving growing
yeah how has quarantine been for you
like
what are you doing just in your life
what are you doing like what the heck is
keith urban doing in in court
i'm gonna chat with keisha
making a fire album i wish i could
i can't cook i really wish i could cook
how many things did everybody
say they're gonna do with this lockdown
period ago i got months to learn a new
language or a new skill and did
nothing and came
[Music]
knowing more about record making um you
know which i do every time i make
records but
spending as much time as i did in the
studio at my house which was
really a godsend having a studio at the
house
made the finishing of the record
possible and the other thing i realized
through this period
was getting back to being creative with
limited
resources um
you know just even in the opening track
out the cage
that i did with breeland and two other
guys from nashville
um yeah we there were so many things i
wanted to do on that record
recording-wise i wanted this
50-person choir at the breakdown section
of the song i wanted an orchestra here
and of course they're like well
that's not happening so what else we're
going to do and breeland who's a great
singer
who said well what about i stack all the
vocal parts
like i'll be the choir and so um
we recorded his vocals like over 50
times singing everybody's part
in the choir multi-tracking and the end
result was
amazing but it was all born of
limitation like okay
we've got to use what we got in front of
us yeah it takes you
back to the beginning you know of you of
a career when you when you work like
that it's pretty cool
totally um yeah there's a lot of really
great collaborations
speaking of breeland obviously this is
an incredible newcomer
bringing diversity to country music what
kind of advice would you pass along to
someone
new like breeland who's at the start of
their career
got a great handle on all of it he is
really talented
very woke smart and deeply gifted and
equally sweet
human being it's a great combination
winning combination but he's immensely
talented
yeah yeah so no advice you don't need to
give him anything
i mean we all need advice but do we take
it you know
i think um the only advice i always
think about is just making sure you've
got people around you that are
brutally honest with you you know too
many people end up with sycophantic
people who just think everything you do
is great and too agreeable
and you need people around you who are
really honest with you yeah
um i've had that my whole life and that
that's really important to keep around
you
yeah who is the most honest person in
your life
me who tells you yeah
yeah i i ideas myself um
uh i think it's it's it's part of
growing up in australia
too you know australia's it's brutally
honest
here when i grew up playing in the clubs
you you know you might play a few songs
someone come up with a good
mate that song you play did you write
that one okay yeah they go that's a
terrible song um but what was the one
after that
i'm like oh i wrote that one too and
they go that second one was good that
first one
terrible and just like straight up just
boom you know and
it's it's actually a good way to grow up
because you build resilience but you
built
to take things on the chin and
and learn and grow yeah definitely yeah
you have a lot of great collaborations
on this pink eric church
now rogers of course breeland uh who
surprised you the
most
oh wow uh i don't know that surprised me
the most
i i reached out to all the people that i
felt like i knew what they did obviously
someone like pink i mean
good lord i mean she's god she's
you know i mean it's pink and there's a
reason why she's pink
and nobody else is uh hearing her voice
on that song on one too many
man it was unbelievable that is a that's
a
stunning stunning gift that she has and
again her as a person
um it's also why she's been around a
long time she's absolutely astounding it
was great to get to do that with her
yeah given that it's covered making this
project collaborating with all these
people like
pink um obviously you can't be in the
same
room with them can you was there any
option to do that
no uh with with breelan we figured out
how to do that because he he's in
atlanta so it was in driving distance to
nashville he drove there and we worked
out how to be in the room at the same
time
uh with pink she's out in california
it's a bit more of a drive
so she um she did her vocals out there
but even even that's not uncommon in our
worlds
at any given time i mean i recorded uh
the fighter with carrie underwood under
the
same kind of situation she was out
touring somewhere and
found a studio out there on the road and
recorded her vocals out there so
and i facetimed her when she was doing
them you know
we were doing that five years ago you
know remotely so um
we were sort of prepared for how we
needed to do things this time around
yeah so the speed of now part one
what the heck does that mean keith now
we got how many more parts is there
going to be i know there's gonna be part
two is there a part three
have no idea i i don't know it might be
a back to the future situation right um
i uh or farewell concerts for some bands
that just go on and on
uh i don't know i know that i recorded
way too many
songs for this record and i really loved
them and
um choosing which ones made this record
and and was was hard
actually what that wasn't hard pushing
songs off you know
was really difficult i felt like i was
deciding who gets in the lifeboat who
doesn't
and uh i thought well what do i do i can
only fit so many in the lifeboat and i
said
need a couple of lifeboats so at least
at least a couple
yeah oh a couple so we get like a part
three or
like i'm trying to get this out of you
like we're getting a part four like how
many are we talking
i got i got one right now and i'm just
an in the moment kind of guy so
okay we'll take it a step at a time all
right i'll be i'll be
i'll be watching you all right um yes
at the stage of the game for you what
makes you want to take on a song like
what captures your interest what
what inspires you what gets you creative
oh gosh it's just a it's just jana
sequoia it's just a it's just a
it's a it's who knows where inspiration
comes from
um yeah for me a lot of times just sheer
curiosity
is probably the biggest driving force of
all i mean
real genuine fascination and curiosity
with what happens if i collaborate with
this person what happens if i bring this
instrument
into a studio what happens if i use this
drum beat and that instrument
and this and what what happens with that
you know i always use
the cooking metaphor because i can't i
can't cook i wish i could
but the studio for me is is like the
kitchen and i bring in all these
different ingredients and just start
seeing what works what doesn't too much
of this not enough of that
and try and get combinations that feel
right
and uh and taste good yeah
what kind of music are you listening to
other than of course your own music but
is there anybody that inspires you or
any shows that you're watching that
you're just loving
yeah uh oh my gosh well we got we got
way deep
into uh succession before um you know
we're waiting for that to get back into
production as i'm sure they are
um tour through um
oh you can't even say shit's creek can
you um yes you can
there it is i just said it i told you
that and we love it
um oh my gosh uh what have we been
loving lately
um oh yellowstone absolutely yeah that's
that's that's been a great watch on tv
and you know musically gosh there's
always something coming out whether it's
uh dua lipa's new record which i love
uh the weeknd's new record it's
fantastic
um there's some great things on the new
chicks record
uh i love jack antonoff as a producer i
think he's done
some really great things on that record
the fusion the collab between him and
the chicks was a really
good one uh taylor's whole new album
i love she's taken her songwriting to a
whole new level
um she's phenomenal so there's a lot of
great stuff out there right now
for part two is there a chance we're
gonna get like a shania twain
miranda lambert
anything like where's this journey going
i want to know
how would you describe your own album um
i've done a collab with miranda uh on
the fuse record that was really fun to
get to sing with her
shania yeah i'm not pro i'm not for
anything i you know who knows
just text her okay
get your phone out
you